this is my home
this is my kitchen
this is my family Tilly Jack
Holly Megan
and of course my wife Tana
you may think you're the busiest person
in the world but over this series I'm
gonna prove it's still possible to cook
stunning food at home
[Music]
my rules are simple home cooking has to
be easy
could be fast it's got to be delicious
[Music]
so if you think you can't cook amazing
food at home think again
these are the only recipes you'll ever
need breakfast lunch and dinner
over the years I've had great fun being
rude about vegetarians but today I'm
joining them I put together a fantastic
breakfast lunch and dinner packed with
amazing tastes textures and full-on
flavor without a bit of meat in sight I
guarantee My ultimate vegetarian food
will have even the most committed
carnivore drooling and begging for more
first up a real treat of a meat-free
breakfast pear and crunchy granola
muffins
for the perfect vegetarian lunch crispy
golden halloumi courgette and Herb cakes
halloumi cheese doesn't look that tasty
but once you've got color on it it's
really delicious and my youngest
daughter Tilly joins me in the kitchen
to make a scrummy three-course veggie
dinner that's my guilty pleasure is it
really courgette Ricotta and mint top
bruschetta roasted beetroot and Thyme
risotto and for put white chocolate and
lime mousse with crushed raspberries
wow that looks really cool the
vegetarian recipe
and dinner first the perfect morning
treat for vegetarians and carnivores
alike pear and crunchy granola muffins
something quite nice when you walk into
friends or family's house and you smell
a muffin being baked the flour and the
baking powder in a nice touch of
cinnamon
cinnamon muffins goes brilliantly pinch
of salt that's really important for the
sort of overall flavor you don't want
the muffin to be too sweet muscovado
sugar that's a refined brown sugar
really rich and somewhat spicy it goes
brilliantly inside the muffin and then
my crispy granola
now we're gonna put half of this in now
and say the other half just sprinkle on
top of the muffin give that a really
good mix
in the center I have some fresh pear top
and tail of the pears really important
to peel nothing worse when you're trying
to enjoy that muffin and you're
negotiating with a big sliver skin of
pear
slice them round the core
sides
a slice them nice and thinly
generally muffins contain around half
the fat and sugar of cupcakes
once the dry ingredients are mixed
together you add in the wet
two whole eggs
nice milk in
followed by gently melted butter
give that a good mix
[Music]
add that to your mixture
start folding
always do it by hand muffins are
delicate dainty little beasts don't
overwork your muffin mixture you want
that mixture to become nice and relaxed
now the mix looks nice and creamy
you'll try
and your little cups
and Spoon in that mixture
two-thirds full
one nice generous spoon and you can tell
the mix is right because you've got that
even distribution of the pear running
from the top to the bottom
just gently tap your tray both ends
that gets the mix all the way down so
they cook nice and evenly
take your granola now sprinkle that on
top so you've got this dual texture
spicy pear and this nice crunchy topping
makes the muffin taste and feel a little
bit more luxurious now into the oven at
180 for 25 minutes
uses
[Music]
they smell delicious
got that nice crispy top just get them
out and let them cool down
and I don't have any problems turning
vegetarian once or twice a week
when I'm having muffins like that
nice they smell amazing
[Music]
a vegetarian breakfast to put hairs on
your chest pear and crunchy granola
muffins
that the Vegetarian Delight beautiful
[Music]
coming up I'll be showing you a stunning
vegetarian lunch and dinner
but first here's a more in-depth look at
the key ingredients you'll need for them
first for dinner I'm using risotto rice
risotto is a flagship classic in Italian
cuisine but is widely believed that the
Spaniards introduced it to Northern
Italy back in the Middle Ages there are
three main types Arborio kanaroli and
violoni
their ability to absorb liquid and
flavor whilst releasing lots of starch
is what makes risotto uniquely delicious
and anxious
a tasty creamy and inexpensive way to
satisfy lots of tummies without a morsel
of meat in sight
[Music]
the Deep dramatic red color of sweet
earthy beetroot makes it difficult to
outdo in terms of all-round culinary
impact
but early forms of this humble room veg
were carrot shapes and favored for their
medicinal rather than their cooking
merits today there is a veritable
rainbow of beetroot types to be enjoyed
pickled in soups grated into cakes or
even simply roasted which is how I'll be
using mine in my amazing vegetarian main
course risotto
Louie is a firm springy salty cheese
with its roots firmly in Cyprus and
Greece the better Lumi is made from
sheep's milk rich in vitamins and
essential nutrients is thought to
promote longevity
halloumi keeps for many months if stored
unopened in the fridge and its high
melting point makes it brilliantly
adaptable perfect for grilling barbecue
and frying I'll be champing this texture
lending Marvel for my yummy vegetarian
lunch dish of halloumi courgette and
Herb cakes
as a chef I'm never sniffy about cooking
with vegetables because I know that with
a bit of care and attention they can be
turned into something absolutely
stunning for my ultimate vegetarian
lunch I've got a couple of fantastic
recipes
lightly fried my delicious halloumian
courgette cakes squeeze every last bit
of flavor out of those vegetables
but first i'm preparing a simple slow
roast tomato and Watercress salad
it's cherry tomatoes are perfect if you
haven't got cherry tomatoes Vine
Tomatoes good or even just big normal
plum tomatoes lay the tomatoes on the
tray
and these go into the oven for about 90
minutes
you turn the oven down really low you
can leave them in overnight to be honest
the longer you leave them the better
they taste
once you've seasoned them with salt
sprinkle over with some sugar
on the salt and sugar combined speeds up
the drying process because you want that
nice chewy texture and then you get
these little thyme flowers and just pick
off the buds garlic sliced
then just spread that on
now the tray looks quite full and
compact for 90 minutes in the oven
you'll see everything shrink down all
the Skins blistering and the flavor
intensifies so nicely extra virgin olive
oil that gives a nice earthy flavor to
the tomatoes
place your Tomatoes into an oven
preheated to 150 degrees C and cook long
and slow for an hour and a half
now halloumi cakes there's something
quite exciting about halloumi cheese
it's a very firm cheese and it fries
brilliantly
[Music]
foreign
great not too finely you want that nice
texture
next courgette the secret is keeping it
all grated the same put that into a
sieve
a sprinkling of salt will draw out
liquid from the vegetables
then grate the halloumi halloumi cheese
doesn't look that tasty but once you've
got color on it in the pan it's really
really delicious now
really important to squeeze out the
excess water in the veg and we'll see
all that water that needs to come out of
there
if we didn't do this it will make your
little patties non-friable because the
whole thing starts to separate and then
mix in with the cheese
spring onions chop up the whites and the
greens
now we're going to season that with some
delicious fresh mint and fresh coriander
whenever it's vegetarian I like to put a
combination of herbs in there tarragon
and parsley minted coriander basil and
lemongrass
all delicious on their own but in tandem
their flavors play off each other
next
two eggs in give that a little mix
add the eggs to the mixture
and then finally a couple of tablespoons
of breadcrumbs the breadcrumbs help dry
out any excess moisture mix
all the ingredients together
before you start shaping these taste the
mixture
it's really important to identify the
seasoning now if you wait until you've
cooked them it'll be too late to adjust
the seasoning
roll them to large golf ball shape them
it's like a little mini burger
you can spice these up with some chili
in there if you haven't got fresh chili
chili flakes and it's something that can
be done up a day in advance
to get your cakes firm and ready for
frying put them into the fridge
uncovered for 25 minutes pan on get that
nice and hot boss I'm waiting for that
I'll get the dressing ready
slice of red chili seeds and all on an
angle into shards
then chop fresh ginger
a Sprinkle of sugar and salt
add some rice wine vinegar
add a couple of tablespoons of olive oil
to finish off some chopped coriander
[Music]
got that sweet sour spicy flavor with my
chili dressing done I can start frying
off my halloumi cakes in a hot oiled pan
look at that nice crisp Edge
you can already start to smell that
sauteed halloumi with the courgettes and
carrots smells delicious really
important put a nice amount of color on
them
as my cakes Sizzle away I can finish off
my roast tomato salad
one of my favorite leaves has to be the
Watercress it's cut off stalks
[Music]
shallot rings
Watercress and shallot
they're brilliantly well together
shallot looks so dainty when you open up
these little ringlets
don't forget to turn your cakes
now Tomatoes whatever you don't use just
jar them and put them in the fridge
um
just drop those slow cooked warm
Tomatoes over the Watercress the
sweetness is incredible absolutely
delicious a little drizzle of age of
ultimate vinegar gives that tartness to
the watercress
Watercress is naturally peppery so it
doesn't need any pepper just a little
touch of salt
and then a light sprinkling of extra
virgin olive oil
to five minutes on a medium heat my
halloumi cakes are ready
so important to have taken out that
water
[Music]
you can see it doesn't disintegrate
and then just get your dressing take a
spoon of it and then tilt it to the side
because I want the garnish I don't want
the juice that does not
turn you on to become a vegetarian for
the night I honestly don't know what
will
delicious
[Music]
my crispy golden halloumi courgette and
Herb cakes with a Sumptuous roast tomato
and Watercress salad all of the flavor
would none of the meat
coming up things get heated in the
kitchen
as Tilly helps me cook a three-course
veggie banquet
wow like it's snowing
[Applause]
[Music]
when I was growing up my mum was a very
very good cook so we had some great food
but it was always meat and two veg and
the veg definitely played a bit past but
the more attention you pay to cooking
vegetables the more you realize they can
easily take Center Stage for all the
flavor with none of the flesh here's my
ultimate vegetarian dinner
first a hearty starter a bruschetta with
ricotta and succulent griddled
courgettes for my main I'm serving
fragrant roasted beetroot and Thyme
risotto
[Music]
but I'll be in trouble with the kids if
I don't do it but
so I'm enlisting the help of my youngest
Tilly to rustle up an indulgent
chocolate and lime mousse with crushed
raspberries
so if you want to wrap the chocolate
start breaking up in Little Bits we're
gonna make the most amazing white
chocolate mousse our first job is to
bring half of our cream up to the boil
so what kind of cream is that in there
dad that is double cream okay so that's
gonna make a really nice rich chocolate
mousse what's your favorite sort of
chocolate is it white milk dark
um I love white milk what's yours I
absolutely love milk chocolate oh that's
my guilty pleasure is it really here we
go cream in
so that goes in there now you can see
what's happening straight away can't you
it's melting really quickly melting
really quickly so okay oh excuse me at
least your Jumper's white so you won't
spot it yeah I've got a nice little
snack for later
in another Bowl add lime zest cold cream
and whisk until it forms soft peaks the
lime cuts the sort of richness of the
cream and that starts to make the
chocolate mousse taste a little bit
lighter
mmm it smells really good the lime gives
it a really nice zinginess you're
absolutely right next add to the melted
chocolate mixture
and because I'm whisking it's just
getting lighter and lighter and lighter
have a little taste
mmm
nice yeah the line gives it a really
nice taste Tilly I need the rest for the
mousse I need some for my tummy no come
on chocolate mousse into the fridge
our next job is to separate out three
egg whites this is where I need you at
your absolute best okay because to whip
those whites it's going to be really
tough so we'll take you in turns 30
seconds each okay you go first
thank you
ten seconds gone
come on silly 15 seconds gone
20 seconds gone come on you can do it 10
seconds to go
five four three two one and change
excellent hold the ball right no
[Music]
come on it's over dad
Matilda
you can't do that to me 30 seconds this
puny little thing and you come with a
big
that's the best way of whipping up egg
whites
slowly
don't look very happy in there
a contentious whipped egg whites will
make our mousse light and Airy and when
they've reached soft peaks we can gently
mix in our cooled white chocolate and
cream mixture
once the egg whites hit the cream yeah
the chocolate sets the egg whites keep
the cream nice and fluffy and you get
this nice light mousse in the bowl now I
need you to crush some raspberries
please with some fresh mint
let's see all the juice coming out
now take your mousse
wow that looks really cool now look at
that down the bottom though
crushed raspberry delicious now I'm
going to set that in the fridge if you
use a can I open the door please our
yummy white chocolate mousse will take
at least two hours to set so we can
crack on with our Mediterranean inspired
vegetarian starter
griddle courgette Ricotta and mint
bruschetta
for this recipe you'll need a griddle
pan an essential piece of kit for that
char grill look
cut thick slices of chapata bread
drizzle both sides with olive oil
season with a little salt and pepper
and griddle each side until toasted
then slice a couple of courgettes
diagonally into half a centimeter thick
pieces drizzle and coat in olive oil and
season with salt and pepper
sear on a smoking hot griddle pan in
batches until all the courgettes are bar
marked on both sides
next roughly chop mint leaves and
combine with creamy ricotta cheese
spread your toasty to your pattern with
dollops of minty Ricotta and top with
your seared courgette
super simple and super tasty
now we're going to make a delicious
beetroot risotto we need to get the
shallots
just slice them in half and then just
chop them like that okay okay now have
you ever made a risotto
shallots please into the pan for Daddy
add a Sprinkle of salt and pepper along
with a couple of crushed cloves of
garlic once you start cooking the
risotto it's really important
to have your stock
gently boiling away
if we're adding cold stock on top of the
rice all the time it just slows down the
process
generally you cook a nice wide flat pan
if you cook in a deep pan all the rice
sort of Cooks at different temperatures
that in there dad because that's a
vegetable stock yeah because you can't
have different stocks if it's for
vegetarian can you stop I made that
mistake once putting beef stock in the
vegetarian soup pictures no I didn't
Matilda
sure I'm positive I'm joking
for our time how nice is that smell it
smells
delicious rice in that's a bit of a
different rice this is Arborio rice it's
a perfect rice for risotto now it's
really important to sear
the rice if we were just to put the
stock in without sweating off the rice
it goes all starchy so keep on stirring
for Daddy
I'm just gonna make it no flambe on the
risotto
let's go with our deep red beetroot
theme I'm adding red wine followed by
the first Ladle of stock to get things
started now we're off wow it's giving it
a cloudy sort of look
[Music]
what's happening to the stock
is reducing down and the rice is sucking
it in that's right so the rice is
actually getting nice and plump one of
risotto is live when it's like this now
we can't stop cooking it we have to cook
it all the way okay ready for the next
ladle
good girl here we go Ladle in
so we have to make this for literally 20
25 minutes and we're nursing it all the
way
beetroots
peel them brought them a little bit of
salt and sugar yeah and a little bit of
aged bathroom vinegar in there roasted
them I'm a great
my parmesan
how's that Rice doing rice is doing good
no
did not want to be now a lot we've got
that nice glossy textured rice so
beetroot I want you to put two thirds of
the beetroot in there for me saving one
third for the top
good sprinkle the parmesan in there for
me please all over
yeah and then we're just gonna get some
nice butter in there
the butter gives the risotto a really
nice gloss look at that beautiful
let that come down let it come down
first
all right get your spirit in there
enough Daddy
okay there you go good wonderful shaking
risotto should be like lava
just
flows out and then the rest of the beer
on top
[Music]
and some extra virgin olive oil
I'll pick up the bruschetta you take
that to the table
okay
let's go die
this is my ultimate vegetarian dinner
delicious courgette Ricotta and mint top
bruschetta an anxious roasted beetroot
and Thyme risotto
and put an indulgent white chocolate and
lime mousse with fresh crushed
raspberries
a delicious non-meat feast that will
have vegetarians and carnivores fighting
for seconds nice is vegetarian nights
Mega how is it though really tasty
we had fun
so where's Holly
discus aren't very nice they hurt your
ears
cheers everybody no meat vegetarian
vegetarians
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the App Store good luck
next time is my ultimate comfort food
you're gonna do it do it properly dishes
packed with love and fond memories I'll
give you a little taste of that
[Music]
thanks for the warning foreign
okay today's all about healthy food I'm
going to show you that eating well and
eating healthily can go hand in hand I'm
a chef so my whole day not just meal
times is devoted to food if I'm not
cooking it I'm tasting it or thinking
about it my other great Passion life is
Fitness I've run over 10 marathons in
the last 10 years I have to get these
two sides of my life to work together
so get ready for my ultimate healthy
recipes dishes that are good for you
without any compromise on flavor to
start a fresh and fruity breakfast to
set you up for the day quick Birch and
muesli you can make in minutes next a
liquid lunch which is generally healthy
glorious gazpacho soup followed by a
wafer thin pineapple capaccio for
dessert
for dinner it's my youngest daughter
Tilly joining me in the kitchen to cook
up a simple meal packed with goodness
teriyaki salmon filled with Amiga oils
and superfood soba noodle salad
for dessert a delicious light and fizzy
Spritz jelly he would say done this is
my ultimate healthy food breakfast lunch
and dinner
first up is my breakfast Bircher muesli
Bertram usually traditionally gets made
the night before and left in the fridge
I find that a little bit too heavy and
slightly stodgy so it's the same
principles but a lot lighter first in
the yogurt I think live and raw milk
yogurt are best they're packed with
calcium enzymes and probiotics which
help your body absorb nutrients
it's interesting because the kids
especially would prefer them usually
with milk but the yogurt it's so much
better for them I like making it
literally 10 minutes before I want to
serve it because it doesn't become
stodgy yoga in
apple juice has a great way of
sweetening the muesli a couple
tablespoons in
give that a little mix
sprinkle in the oats
I like putting two-thirds in now to
absorb an almost double in size and the
last third of oats in at the end oats
are low on the glycemic index which
means they slowly release energy to keep
you going right through to lunch I quite
like it when it just falls off the spoon
you can see literally in seconds it's
gone thicker
the rest of the oats in
so I've got different textures now mix
that up nicely
and it literally takes three or four
minutes to put together
it's gonna get a dry pan on
one's incredibly healthy toasting them
even better flavor
flake them into the pan lightly toast
them
that gives a really nice sort of crunch
to the top of the music
[Music]
roll around the pan so they're evenly
toasted
out into a bowl
the exciting thing about putting your
own music together is that you're in
control blackberries summer raspberries
strawberries and so it changes berries
don't just taste great they're packed
with antioxidants and vitamin C and K so
just Dot
the top of your muesli with your black
rose generous on the blackberries
sweetness and tartness
acidic
and then just sprinkle over
you're nice ones
I quite like a lot of crunch on top
so be generous
that looks fantastic
perfect way
to start the day
my quick Birch and muesli doesn't just
taste incredible it makes you feel
fantastic it's my ultimate healthy
breakfast there really is no better way
to start the day
[Music]
thank you next I'm putting the flavor
back into healthy food with a
sensational lunch and dinner
here are the key ingredients you'll need
to cook them
[Music]
first on my ultimate shopping list are
soba noodles these gray brown noodles
are made from buckwheat so they're
gluten free and high in protein
they're quick to cook and so versatile
use them in stir fries soups and salads
like the one I'm making for dinner
thank you
[Music]
when Philips are brimming with super
healthy Amiga oils and so quick and
versatile to cook whether poached
grilled pan-fried baked or quickest of
all raw or sushi
I'm making a family favorite for my
healthy dinner teriyaki salmon
pomegranates have been revered since
ancient Greek and Egyptian times for
healing properties today we know these
little Jewels are packed with
antioxidants minerals and vitamins b c e
and K they are fantastic in Middle
Eastern dishes or scattered over fruit
salads like the fine pineapple capaccio
I'm making for lunch
I don't believe in fatty diets and diet
foods there's no cardboard tasting rice
cakes in our house let me tell you at
its simplest healthy eating for me is
all about fresh home-cooked food portion
control and a balanced diet and it
should be a pleasure to eat you should
never turn meal times into something you
dread for my ultimate healthy lunch I'm
showing you on my favorite dishes it's
packed with vitamins and goodness but
it's also super tasty gazpacho
for dessert sweet and refreshing
pineapple like you've never tasted
before first job the gazpacho soup for
me the secret of a great gazpacho is
over ripe tomatoes
Peppers cucumber a little bit of heat
with a garlic
we've got to leave it to marinade first
Peppers cut around the flat edges to
minimize waste
then chop the nice thing about
making a dispatcher there's no set
recipe because you can put it together
purely all tomatoes
half Peppers half tomatoes
I like the flavor of the cucumber in
there as well that gives it that
freshness
The Secret of a great dispatcher is the
longer you leave it marinating
the better the flavor
so if you can get this done the night
before and left in the fridge
the results are stunning the green and
red peppers have subtly complementary
flavors and go well with ripe Tomatoes
start off by removing the bitter core a
little knife
and just
put it in where the core is and twist it
round and you get this little core out I
remember my first experience
eating a gazpacho in Spain
mind-blowing I've never forgotten that
quarter your Tomatoes keeping the juicy
seeds that add so much depth of taste
nice then from there cucumber just peel
that seeds I'm going to leave in
that gives it the flavor and the texture
cucumber and gazpacho
does exactly what it does in a pims it
sort of freshens it up
and makes it mouth-watering slice that
in half
again into quarters and chop
now to give gazpacho its unique texture
and thicken the soup bread and the
crispy the crust the better then garlic
thinly sliced
next spring onions nice and roughly
chopped and basil stalks and all we can
use stalks and basil stalks parsley
stalks tarragon stalks they have the
most amazing flavor basil and
for now I'm going to start marinating
salt black pepper and a good coating of
olive oil this gives it a glossy creamy
flavor
and the Cherry vinegar that's the
perfect vinegar
for the gazpacho it's a strong acidic
complement to the flavors
then just mix it up and smell already
it's incredible
it doesn't look
like a gazpacho but by the time this
marinades and all those flavors start
getting to know one another
all of a sudden you've got this huge
explosion of contrast
now
push that down in the restaurants we
press the marinade down overnight a
couple of big pans on top and we Crush
all the ingredients and then Blitz it
the next day
flavor is extraordinary leave all those
fresh ingredients packed with goodness
to marinate from half an hour to even
overnight and then when you blend it it
just comes together like this Sumptuous
Rich delicious chilled soup to go with
my super tasty soup I've got an ultra
healthy and exciting dessert capaccio of
pineapple which is a Chevy way of saying
super thinly sliced it's done with a
Twist
we're gonna have a delicious flavored
salt
has to be flavored with vanilla simply
scrape out the vanilla seeds and add to
sea salt along with the Pod to store now
that basically keeps forever there's no
sale by date because it's salt and
vanilla so
so fragrant so delicious you don't need
much of this fragrant salt to intensify
the sweetness of the pineapple
the pineapple
[Music]
sliced peeled pineapple into wafer thin
pieces so what's that nice little discs
slightly transparent
[Music]
once you've sliced the pineapple take
the flavor to another level
a light sprinkle of vanilla salt and
arrange the pineapple in a flower shape
[Music]
it's a beautiful way of finishing
a meal
fragrance
other than the crunch
with the salt
and the vinegar salt just marinades
the pineapple beautifully then scatter
nutrient-rich pomegranate seeds over the
top to finish finely shredded fresh mint
just
slicing
really thin
and then I'll give that nice cool minty
flavor
the pineapple my Carpaccio is ready and
my gazpacho has been marinating in the
fridge time to blend the soup
and
onto your blender
start off nice and slowly
blend until super fine and gloriously
silky and serve refreshingly cold
get your bowl
and pour it in
now to finish it get some fresh basil
roll it nice and tight
and shred it
and then drop it into your bowl
fresh
chop basil and then finally
just a touch of extra virgin olive oil
just to give that a really nice
additional freshness
and look at that healthy and delicious
gazpacho soup to me is a taste of
Mediterranean sunshine in a bowl
followed by the way for thin Carpaccio
of pineapple with jewels of pomegranate
goodness for dessert
practically all of your five a day in
one incredible healthy lunch
coming up it's dinner time and my
youngest Tilly shows she's champion of
healthy cooking a bit like pure gold
with a winning way to eat salmon
I think we did well high five
[Applause]
[Music]
it's not just me my whole family is
pretty sport mad my wife Tana runs
marathons Jack's crazy about football
and swimming Megan loves swimming too
and is in the local Club Holly's mad
about hockey and Tilly plays netball for
the school so a healthy diet is an
important one but we're pretty relaxed
about it my philosophy is simple try and
eat less of the bad stuff and eat more
of the good stuff and Johnny me in the
kitchen is my netball nut youngest Tilly
for dinner it's Amiga Rich teriyaki
salmon with a buckwheat soba noodle
salad brimming with healthy greens and a
light aperol Spritz jelly for dessert
first job the teriyaki marinade for the
salmon silly
gonna help Daddy with a salmon please
right
Teriyaki delicious
sticky sweet salmon okay first of all
I'd like you
a little season on the salmon please
with salt and pepper thank you
all right I want you to slice the garlic
one in front two behind yep
oh oh get a bit faster in the old age
huh good girl
thank you right garlic in with the
ginger
so we're gonna make a marinade
okay do you know what a marinade is it's
what you coat something in that's right
so let's start off with
soy sauce three tablespoons one good
good
this is rice wine also known as mirin
one in
I know what that is that's maple syrup
it's a bit like pure gold
beautiful and a little touch of olive
oil
it smells really good
I need to rub
the salmon in the marinade if you can
get a chance to do this the night before
the salmon actually changes color but
it's fine even with 10 or 15 minutes
before you start cooking it does the
ginger and garlic give it a different
taste
you know what it helps improve the taste
when we cook it I have this really nice
glaze on there okay right let's put that
in the fridge to marinade and we'll
start the jellies
to follow the teriyaki salmon a grown-up
light dessert Prosecco an aperol Spritz
jelly
start by soaking gelatine sheets in cold
water
poor Prosecco 100 milliliters of water
and caster sugar into the pan heat until
the sugar is dissolved then add your
gelatin sheets
leave the mix to cool top up with more
Prosecco and a dash of the Bittersweet
Italian aperol
then pour into tumblers over orange
slices and leave to set in the fridge
all the refreshment of a spritz in a
perfect jelly form
the Teriyaki Salmon's marinating time to
get on with the noodle and vitamin pan
veg and seed salad
noodles
they're this color because they're made
out of Buckwheat okay and then we're
going to drop them in
so nice and careful if you slide them
that way
and then you go like that in your hand
and I'll show you there
and then look
hold them like that and drop them into
the pan okay got them yeah okay so hold
on tight off you go
nice do they take longer to cook than
normal noodles
literally five minutes now what are they
sugar snap peas
okay you're so crunchy really crunchy
now
carrot
and kale
I'll show you a really quick way of
slicing carrot ribbons so just come down
peeling number that's right off you go
there we go
nice big long ribbons sugar snap peas in
yeah okay into the noodles
you've got two
oh thank you wake up daddy next
kale now you know how good that is for
you right yeah kale in right how the
ribbons okay good oh that's nice
you okay like some salt and pepper you a
little bit carrot
ribbons go in
good girl I didn't forget any like you
did so excuse me and because we've
shaved them really thinly like this
how long do you think they're going to
take to cook
about a minute oh it looks so yummy it
does look yummy doesn't it now we're
going to drain
the noodles
that is beautiful see how the kales go
what happens if you cook um the
vegetables for too long would they just
go a bit hard they'll go soft and mushy
okay
and then
we're gonna drop the noodles
then
but now
I'm gonna make those noodles taste even
better I'd like you to put a little bit
of salt and pepper on there for me
please
next
I'm gonna put a dressing on there Ginger
goes in
You Can Count Me
how nice is it gonna be like a
multi-season salad isn't it the colors
yeah
um Sesame
[Music]
a touch assessment over
okay rice wine vinegar
a little splash
okay
and then finally
and it will touch of soy sauce and let
you drizzle that in please
that's it
one little final
ingredient what's that seaweed whose
favorite is that Jack's Holly's
slice it into strips
okay I'm gonna chop that
oh how is that
good I want you to sprinkle that on top
of the noodles
but I'll squeeze the lemon juice
oh excuse me
I also had a lemon shower today
sober noodle salad is ready now
we'll get on and cook the salmon
oh it looks good doesn't it
boom let's go
right pan nice and hot what did I show
you when you put fish in the pan which
way did you put in
you put it in um skin down that's right
and then there's the pan there and you
put it in there and you lay away from
you if you lay it towards you what
happens it will spit at you it will
Splash that's right so take your time
good girl
here we go
and the last one good girl very slippy
very slippy
it's not so fresh nice nice a nice
little bit of Ginger on there now a
little bit of garlic it smells of a
mixture of all the flavors doesn't it
it's color on the salmon
[Music]
that's right
I'm gonna like you to pour the rest of
marinade over for me please
nice
okay
Now The Summer's gonna glaze now well
done you're getting good at this cooking
stuff you know that would you like to be
a chef when you grow up yeah really we
don't have your own restaurant one day I
might have a bakery a bakery me and Jack
are planning on opening one together and
you do the paninis and make the coffees
and I do the cakes in the cookie then
it's gonna have like scrambled eggs for
breakfast so you've already thought this
out yeah we were planning it the other
night and when we couldn't sleep and
who's gonna be the head chef and who's
gonna be the sous chef no we're not
gonna do that because we've both got
different rolls in it oh I see this is
well thought out yeah but there's We're
not gonna need anybody else apart from
me and him so no other people that was
nice it sounds amazing
you got the spoon here like this okay
and just tilt the pan I'll tilt the pan
you glaze the salmon for me please
now
very my darling uh ready I'm ready
do you keep the ginger on top of it
what was your favorite type of salmon
when you were little
salmon fish cakes
oh I like those you like those
how does that look that looks delicious
I'd like you to carry that very
carefully over to the table okay and
I'll carry your noodles ready
let's go well done
so I'm fascinated with this restaurant
you and Jack are going to open yeah
this is my ultimate healthy dinner it's
fresh home-cooked and full of goodness
but most importantly it's absolutely
delicious
[Music]
so we have a delicious turkey salmon
with sober noodles
thank you
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the App Store good luck
next time it's my ultimate home-cooked
street food something quite exciting
about eating spice for breakfast finger
licking treats that will have everyone
racing indoors to sit down and eat I
love fried chicken I love it more than
you did
[Music]
thank you
foreign